this is my big rule of intuition go
immediately with the first thing that
pops into your head the second you start
justifying it's just gone I've heard the
statement don't judge a book by it's
cover but I admit that I do sometimes I
think I'm really good at reading people
because I can sense before they even say
anything kind of like what conversation
is going to ensue that's like a
superpower
I'm just intuitive baby you just know
yeah you know that you're we're gonna
take a quiz today to test our ability to
read people see how intuitive we
actually are let's take the quiz let's
do is screaming Jason every Jason I've
ever known has been like a more
adventurous outdoorsy type of person
camo pants Jason black shirt Jason I'm
gonna say D it looks like I want to say
Dirk my name is Jason you're cool we
know who you are oh yeah look at that
Jason who's the Sara first instincts
were a I'm gonna go with a Sarah's look
like the girl next door type smart they
look unassuming it's like the quiet
determination I'm leaning towards see
just looked by the way she's standing
she very composed
generally they look like softer people
like they have kind eyes she seems very
kind of how she's holding her hands or
something like delicate about her Sarah
that's it Sarah is an approachable girl
I am saying B you could just see her
saying hi I'm
how do you think it's be no I think it's
a CC C and I first look at the picture
and you said who's the Sarah a stuck out
to me
Chrissy hmm that's a loaded name that
means so much I'm gonna say D because
she's like I don't give a damn okay I
want to say B she looks like she has
like a fun outgoing personality I feel
like Chrissy's have fun outgoing
personalities like Chrissy Teigen the
outfit has a lot to say the name has a
lot to say B is Crittenden and now I'm
really going with my gut and C I don't
know I my energy gravitated towards the
one in the middle
Chrissy is e be D totally be I'm
connected to a higher energy right now
at school I have so many preconceived
notions about Brooklyn I'm going for C
he gives me like a hipsterish
by like a like artist maybe like an
artiste he looks like he just is like a
Brooklyn implant he also looks like he's
seen some [ __ ] to me it's like oh I've
lived through that I'm over it
it's kind of just mysterious to me D
okay first all the haircut and the plaid
I'm gonna go with Derek Derek who looks
like yeah he looks like a Brooklyn guy
I'm gonna go with B D D also oh whoa all
right yeah okay wow he looks like the
farthest thing from what I was thinking
B is our youngest there was a
playfulness with B she looks young deep
her like a tire is very playful I just
like this aura of like mmm like I'm just
like I'm just doing me that's e d b b
for this one yes the only one that's
habit that has long sleeves is d it's
got something hide deep I'm gonna go
with B he looks like he's hiding
something seems like he would ink his
body with a lot of meaning I think your
artist friend might have some something
like I'm a rebel but my mom likes me I'm
gonna go with C be a name I have tattoos
I know people that have tattoos like I
just can see it I can spot it from a
mile away
who speaks fluent Japanese I'm going
back to our first girl C she just seems
like she knows how to say like konichiwa
no he looks like she looks like very
multilingual she looks very like
educated and like the girl that like
knows 10,000 languages hee-hee-hee for
sure she just looks like she has her
[ __ ] together
she looks very smart and she looks like
a no-nonsense kind of gal like she's
focused all the time she probably has
the discipline to learn this language
they can to see well I take it back tell
me at them up
nihongo got Hakeem Elsa even though I
don't look like it I do speak Japanese
interesting did not play a sport in high
school the judgest of all judgy times is
high school we have to channel that
energy bear see actually that doesn't
make sense
do you definitely look like a basketball
player hey no hey he's the only one with
his shirt talk to him I'm gonna go with
C cuz he's seated yes it looks too cool
for school like extracurriculars what
I'm going with B hey yeah see see see as
well okay he couldn't count yes he
couldn't care less I don't know but I'm
very excited about who looks like they
were like I need the most impressive
party trick of all time be again the
to the fire he looks guilty it looks
mischievous it dies he does he
yeah I was thinking as well there is no
reason why I just got it ha ha d I'm
zooming Derek breathes fire I'm gonna
say B B yes their video of that we did
bad terrible we're both bad people and
we're not even good at being bad people
we're judgy but we're not even correct I
did way worse than it it's really hard
to reach people based on how they look
it's okay to have you know first
impressions of people like don't use
that to base your entire opinion of that
person without talking to them
I think intuition is all about trusting
myself honestly just your gut trust your
gut but when it comes to people you are
conditioned to have certain reactions
that will cloud your judgment when push
comes to shove always go with C there
you go kid